- Growing up in poverty
and mom was on welfare for over 10 years.
But she never let any of that
affect her in a negative way.
Say you worry about a problem.
So, here you are worrying
and all this stuff.
And all the sudden the problem's solved.
All that anguish for nothing.
See, the physical application
of karate really is
the smallest part of it.
And there's this one Indian
kid who just didn't like me.
And everyday he'd chase
me home from school.
I must have a direction for
me to get up in the morning.
I got to know what it
is that I want to do.
So, all four of us fight.
My three students win and I lose.
Anything you work toward,
there are always obstacles in the way.
- He's an american martial
artist, actor, and film producer.
After serving in the
United States Air Force
he began his rise to
fame as a martial artist.
He appeared in a number of action films
and had the starring role in the TV series
Walker Texas Ranger.
He's Chuck Norris
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
- Growing up in poverty
and mom was on welfare for over ten years.
But she never let any of that
affect her in a negative way.
She always kept a very
positive image about life,
saying that we may be poor
but we're rich in love.
And I've always remembered that.
And she's aways said that and always
kept a positive attitude about life
and that kind of carried off in me too.
And I think that was some
of the success in my life,
is I always kept a positive attitude about
whatever it was I was pursuing.
Chuck Norris (chuckles).
Chuck Norris' tears cure cancer.
Too bad he never cries.
Ever.
(applauding)
- Are you?
Is that true?
You don't worry about things?
- No, because it doesn't do any good.
'Cause the thing is, let's
say you worry about a problem.
So, here you are worrying
and all this stuff.
And all the sudden the problem is solved.
All that anguish for nothing, you know?
The thing is, worrying
doesn't solve the problem.
It actually hinders the problem.
What you've got to do,
is try to find ways of
solving that solution.
Or that problem.
Finding the solution for the problem.
And if you do, then you don't
have time to worry about it.
- You're able to live by that?
- Well, believe me, I've, you know,
from the book, as you know,
I've gone through a lot of ups and downs.
The people see strictly my success.
But they don't know where I came from.
The kid who grew up in the
back hills of Oklahoma,
who was totally non-athletic,
and I won the world karate championship.
And the kid who was
extremely shy in school,
I'd never even done a high
school play or a book report,
now I'm doing this.
The thing is, you find formulas.
You find things that will help you
work toward what you want.
Chuck Norris is currently suing NBC
claiming Law and Order
are trademarked names
for his left and right legs.
(laughing)
- Last one!
Yes!
- See, the physical application
of karate really is,
is the smallest part of it.
Most people think of Karate strictly as
a physical application,
but what it does for you
mentally, psychologically,
and emotionally is much more important
than what the physical attributes can be.
For instance, we teach
success orientation.
Positive-minded type goals.
Because many students
we get into our school
come in there and they're very negative
train of thought.
"I can't do this.
"I can't do that.
"I can't accomplish things."
And what we try to do as teachers,
is to push out all the negative thoughts
and replant positive
ideas of what you can do.
What you can accomplish in life.
And we set formulas, for them.
Which, is very good, works
in all areas of life.
Not strictly karate but
college training or whatever.
And the formula that I emphasize is that,
whatever goal you set for yourself,
which we all do.
As we get into the adult world,
we all set goals for ourselves.
The first thing you must have
is a mental image in your mind
of what it is that you want to accomplish.
Like, you're going to college now,
you know what in your mind
of what it is that you want to achieve.
Secondly, you must be determined
and persistent enough to
stick with it long enough.
Now this is where a lot of people fail
because whether you're
going through college
to get your master's or whatever,
you're going to hit obstacles en route.
You know, it gets tough at times.
And a lot of times people will quit
because of these obstacles in the way.
And we always emphasize the fact that
you must be determined to
overcome each obstacle en route.
And that if you'll study, or
train, whatever it may be,
accordingly there's not
a thing in the world
that you cannot achieve.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- This is one of my favorites here.
When the boogeyman goes
to sleep every night,
he checks his closet for Chuck Norris.
(boisterous laughing)
- There is a scene in there
where you talked about
bullies and running from danger
and things like that when you
were trying to help this kid.
- Yeah.
What happens is this boy is being harassed
by the neighborhood bully.
And his father is encouraging his son
to beat up this little boy.
And I wrote this scene.
I wrote this particular
scene in the script.
And I was trying to think,
what can I write
to encourage this boy to
handle this situation,
you know, with this bully
in the neighborhood?
And I'm spending days
trying to figure out,
what can I say to boy?
And finally I came up with the answer
and it was a situation that I, as a child,
had encountered, at about his age.
I went to school in Arizona
that was mostly Indians
from the reservation.
And there was this one Indian
kid, who just, didn't like me.
And every day he'd chase
me home from school.
And I'd have to run by this gas station.
And this mechanic watched me being chased
by this Indian kid every day.
And finally he just
couldn't handle it anymore
and he stopped me and
made me face this boy.
And I told him, I said, you
know I told him I was scared
and he says, well.
And what he said to me,
which, is still true.
Which, I remember.
Is that, he says, "You know
that, running from your fear,
"is more painful than facing it."
And that's something
I've always remembered.
And this is what I relate to this boy.
And of course eventually
he has to face this fear in the film.
In fine print on the last page of
The Guinness Book of World Records,
it notes that all world records
are held by Chuck Norris,
and those listed in the book
are simply the closest
anyone else has ever gotten.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's true.
(audience applauding)
- Again, you learn philosophies as you go.
From experiences in life.
You start learning philosophies and
things that will help you work.
Like, for me, I'm very goal-oriented.
I must have a direction for
me to get up in the morning.
I've got to know what
it is that I want to do.
And it's like when I was a karate fighter,
all I wanted to do was run a local
karate tournament in L.A.
But once I won it, I thought,
well, how about the state title.
So then the state title
became the next goal.
And then when I won that,
there was national,
international, then the world.
And if I would've said, "I
want to be the world champion."
when I first started fighting,
it was too far beyond my conception.
But I had realistic goals.
Goals that I felt, in my
heart, I could achieve.
The same thing in the movie business.
You know, I had no idea
I'd be where I am today,
- Sure
- when I first started.
I just wanted to do a movie.
Anything just to try
to get some experience.
When Chuck Norris sends in his taxes,
he sends blank forms
and includes only a picture of himself,
crouched and ready to attack.
Chuck Norris has never had to pay taxes.
Ever.
That's not true.
That is not true.
(audience laughs)
My first tournament
was in Salt Lake City, Utah.
I take three of my students and myself,
we drive 16 hours to
get to Salt Lake City,
to compete in this tournament.
So, all four of us fight.
My three students win, and I lose.
(audience laughs)
So, I drive back while they
held the trophies, you know.
But, you know, interesting how
philosophies are developed,
because on the way back I'm thinking,
well, what, how come I,
you know, I didn't win?
What was it I did that made me lose?
And so I started going
through the fight in my mind.
And I said, "Okay, I
understand what I did wrong."
And I said, "Okay, I may
make a mistake again,
"but I'm not going to
make the same mistake
"or the same loss again."
And so, philosophies are
developed through this here,
and as I tell my students, I said,
"The only time you ever lose at anything,
"is when you don't learn
from that experience.
"'Cause that's what life is.
Life is full of experiences
and if you learn from them,
you're going to grow."
Chuck Norris doesn't churn butter.
He roundhouse kicks the cows
and the butter comes straight out.
(audience laughs)
- [Interviewer] Now, is that real?
Is that for real?
- Yeah, 'cause I have a ranch,
that's how I get my butter.
Anything you work toward
there are always obstacles in the way.
And that's when you either
quit, or you continue on.
And that's when I say,
"To continue on, overcome that obstacle
"en route to your goal,
"because you never know
which is the last obstacle
"that's going to try to stop you.
"And if you stop, that
could've been the last obstacle
"en route to your success."
Chuck Norris once shot
down a German fighter plane
with his finger by yelling, "Bang!"
(boisterous laughing)
- It's true, it's true.
(Chuck laughs)
- Oh, man.
- [Narrator] Chuck and
his team of Texas Rangers
beat the bad guys from 1993 till 2000.
- In fact, CBS wanted to go
another two years on the series
and I probably would have considered that,
except that my wife was
pregnant with our twins
at that particular time.
Towards the end of the eighth season
and I knew that I couldn't do a series
and take care of my wife
during her pregnancy.
So, I knew it was time
to call an end to it.
Rather than being birthed
like a normal child,
Chuck Norris instead
decided to push his way out,
punch his way out, punch his way out.
(audience cheers)
It's like when I was a fighter,
I'd be walking down the aisle to the ring,
I'd be shaking hands and you know.
And saying, "Hello" to everybody.
But once I walked into the ring,
my whole demeanor changed
because there was a man across the ring
who was going to knock my block off.
And so, I had to change my attitude.
I had to become much more aggressive
and almost animalistic,
and when I fought him.
After the fight was over,
then I'd go back to a
more of a mild individual.
And that's basically the
philosophy of my movies,
the guy who isn't looking for
trouble, tries to avoid it.
But when he's put in to position,
that he's got to face it,
like we would have to do in real life,
then he becomes that person
to deal with that situation.
There are no steroids in baseball.
Only players Chuck Norris has breathed on.
(audience laughs)
(hosts talking over each other)
Believe me, these ought to
be screenplay writers here.
The martial arts changed my whole life.
I was a very shy kid growing up.
And I was terrified to get up
in front of anyone and talk.
All through high school,
I never once got in front of a class
to give a book report or anything.
When the teacher'd call me up and say,
my real name was Carlos, by the way.
But anyway, they'd get up and say,
"Would you come up and
give a book report?"
I'd be sitting at my desk
and I'd go.
And my face would turn beat
red from embarrassment,
but I thought if I got up
there I'd be more embarrassed.
So, I went through that very
insecure time in my life.
Then when I went to
Korea, at the age of 19
and take my black belt and
I came back to the states,
now I'm 22 years old
and I'm stationed at March Air Force base
in Riverside, California.
And I thought, so, I was
doing my martial arts.
Now, this is 1961-62 and
no one really knew anything
about the martial arts at that time.
And so I'm doing my kicks
and punches and all that.
And all the GI's on
the base would watch me
and they'd say, "Will you teach me that?
"Teach us that stuff!"
And I thought, well, maybe
I'll start a club on the base.
So, I decided to give a demonstration
at the gym on the base
and I'll never forget this,
this was 40-something years ago,
and that night I was handing
out notices to everybody
that I'm going to give a demonstration.
And I thought, well, I'm
going to have to give a talk.
And I'm 22 years old and I've
never done this in my life.
So, I wrote out about
a half a page speech.
And I memorized this thing for two weeks.
I could say it forwards,
backwards, sideways, whatever.
The night of the demonstration,
I walk into the gym
and the microphone is lying on the floor.
And I walk up, I pick up the microphone
and I say, "Good evening,
ladies and gentlemen.
"My name is Chuck Norris,
"and I'd like to welcome
you here tonight."
That's the last thing I remember.
The next thing I remember,
I'm walking out into the middle of the gym
to do my demonstration.
And as I'm walking out
there, I'm thinking,
did I finish my speech
or did I just lay the microphone down?
Well, to this day I
still don't really know.
But what was important for me at that time
it cracked the egg of insecurity
that I'd carried around for 22 years.
And then I kept forcing myself
until that egg cracked open.
And of course the results of
all that is becoming an actor.
You know.
Starting a foundation with Kickstart Kids
which, is the love of my life now.
I'm teaching the martial arts
in the inner city schools,
in the middle schools.
Again, using the martial arts
as a tool to help these kids
develop the security in themselves
that I lacked as a youngster
and helping them believe in themselves.
That they can accomplish
anything they want
in their life.
If they're willing to
pay the price for it.
And that's hard work and dedication.
That's the secret
to being successful in your life.
And number 10 is, When
Chuck Norris does push-ups,
he doesn't push himself up.
He pushes the earth down.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Zoh Gonzales asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Chuck Norris'
top 10 rules meant the
most to you and why.
Leave it in the comments
and I will join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe.
And I'll see you soon.
(audience laughing)
- So, you took acting classes and stuff?
- Uh, yeah. Yeah.
I took acting classes.
Even in my acting classes
I couldn't get a part.
- Oh my lord.
(laughing)
That's...
You're struggling.
- That's the truth, that's the truth.
Yeah.
- Well, how'd you break through?
- I don't know.
It just, determination.
You know, and not giving
up and persistence.
And I achieved the goals I
wanted in the karate world.
I did, you know, in the
world title and my schools
and I was trying to
decide what new energies,
where I wanted to direct my energies at
and Steve McQueen, who was one
of my students at the time,
suggested the acting field
and I just finished a movie with Bruce Lee
called Return of The Dragon
so I decided I would pursue that.
Have you ever made a mistake?
Of course you have.
We all have.
Many times it's hard to
face up to that mistake
because it means you may
be laughed at or punished
but when you do face up to your mistake
and know that you'll never do it again,
then you become a much stronger person.
Here's my favorite one.
They want to put Chuck
Norris' face on Mount Rushmore
but the granite wasn't
hard enough for his beard.
- [Presenter] Yes!!
(cheering and laughing)
Got to applaud the effort, Chuck Norris!